la noche después de dos intensas semanas
de discusiones los estados miembros de
la ONU firmaron el primer tratado
internacional para proteger la alta
damas y caballeros
el barco ha llegado a la orilla
valió la pena la espera los activistas
han elogiado el histórico tratado como
un logro trascendental ya que permitirá
la creación de áreas marinas protegidas
en estas aguas Internacionales La
altamar comprende alrededor de dos
tercios en los océanos del mundo y casi
la mitad de la superficie del planeta
dado que se extiende hasta 200 millas
náuticas es en las costas todos los
países pueden usarla para pescar Navegar
y realizar investigaciones pero hasta
ahora solo el 1% de estas aguas han sido
protegidas lo que significa que la vida
Marina en altamar se enfrenta amenazas
como la sobrepesca el tráfico marítimo y
el cambio climático su redacción exacta
aún no ha sido acordada pero el tratado
requerirá que los países realicen
estudios e impacto ambiental de las
actividades propuestas en las aguas
ayudar a proteger los preciosos
ecosistemas del océano que producen la
mitad del oxígeno que respiramos los
humanos y limitan el calentamiento
global al absorber el dióxido de carbono
antes de que se adopte formalmente el
acuerdo deberá ser examinado por
abogados y traducido a los seis idiomas
de la o